fantastic to be joined by Eliot Spencer
we've been friends since we were like
six years old
Eliot you have single-handedly sold over
100 property deals as a deal packager
what are you doing right now a lock down
my friend trying to sell still selling
she's good I'll mustard I'm a big
massive believer you know people are
sitting about doing the thing then
they're those type of people that ain't
gonna help the economy they're not going
about this recession now more than ever
you know is the time to sell it and
throw in some money when you stuck at
home you can even view houses or you
need as a phone and a laptop it's all
you need all right
you were telling me about South Wales
and stuff you'd be looking at some deals
down there I mean are you are you pretty
I mean I don't know if you like me on I
am enjoying and making the most of this
time but I'm desperate for it to end as
well I want to leave the house man yeah
yeah yeah no I definitely want to leave
the house I'm striking yourself a bit
for a walk jog every day but yeah that's
successful no one has said to me oh it's
terrible oh my gosh I'm worried and like
no one said that I've been speaking to
many of my entrepreneurial friends that
successful yourself included and
everyone's just talking about the
opportunities and everyone's trying to
be positive financially I know it's hit
me financially I hope yeah I hope that
I'll end up being richer because of it
but right now I mean I was selling some
houses which which which I had to pull
from auction because I was just getting
stupid office I was I was about to
refinance a load of houses but now the
value is can't go out and it's looking
like I'm not gonna be able to do that
any time soon and they're sending 60%
instead of 75% on training business has
had to completely stop my to counsel how
many but probably dozens of events so
it's it's it's hit me hard
but then as an entrepreneur there's also
opportunities who's created
so I'm now I've put my off of my
training online which is very
cool I'm finding we some of some
property deals that I was looking at saw
like six 12 months ago and the and the
owners were saying no I can't go that
low or no I can't do that lease option
agreement whatever I'm now getting
people call out the woodwork saying
actuate and we have a chat
things are happening opportunities are
opening up I've just recently a saint's
bore a little I mean the process of
buying a piece of land which is going to
be actually free a free piece of land
rambling with joint venture with the
owner and they're gonna get a percentage
of the profits that might not have
happened if it wasn't for this is this
time I think any entrepreneur is or by
definition they have to look at the
positives and try and actually hustle
and make some money which is what you're
doing of course you do
yeah you've got two tops people in this
world you got the one table person loads
poor me poor me it's not my fault but
there's not a lot I can do so I'm gonna
sit back and watch Netflix for the next
6 7 8 weeks or you've got people are
gonna also get their head down and try
and make some money and try and try and
see the positives in the silver lining
of this mess and try and do something
about it I love a challenge and I'm
really enjoying it the minute it is
challenging yes it's it's affected me
expecting my business massively but
there's not a lot we can do so yourself
as your salesperson you're a property
entrepreneur and have you had to adapt
yeah of course yeah a lot of what are
you doing different I can't leave my own
camera that's that's the first thing I
can't leave my answer is no all over the
phone you thinking everything all on the
phone all online all on the phone all
online that's all it is now video calls
em calls I didn't have a zoom account
before this I didn't know what soon was
when you say you're a salesperson that
kind of that kind of like I don't know
people my audience might not like that
because they think hang on and they know
they don't they might know that oh this
is a property channel and you're talking
to all all about sales they won't like
that there are so I have about
conversation with people I'm trying to
sell a product and then I'll having it
again people who have people scared he
grew fear people are losing their jobs
people have had to adapt again
financially
sails at the minute it's it's not it
some people finally frown upon it and
other people yeah and that now that
now's the time to buy you don't have
until every person every entrepreneur
has to realize that they better get good
at sales exactly if you weren't good at
sales before you mind it you might as
well forget it
because now you've got it now you've got
to get really good you know you've got
it you've got it you've got to serve
you've got to serve more you've got to
give more value now more than ever which
is difficult over the phone so you've
got to give more value you've got to
serve and you've got to make them want
the product yeah and listen apologies
anyone who's listening about the bar at
the bad line whether they're not lives
not great but hopefully you can hear
with my man Elliot saying because this
guy I mean you sold over 100 property
deals while you're working with me as a
property sorcerer
what's your I think that everybody needs
to learn to sell in this time if you do
nothing else during this lockdown time
to sell properly learn to sell be no
sell then you're not gonna eat no I must
have a agree I do my spirits what tips
have you got as a salesperson well great
question um tips like I said you've got
it you've got to serve it's not it's not
as easy as it well as it was before
where people probably add spare cash
lying around that they could invest in
in things all the goods the better
themselves in you know additional
courses or mention or training people I
mean people are scared like I said they
don't know they don't want to spend the
money at the minutes they were not all
answer it's the people that are in jobs
they're scared they're gonna get
furloughed or they're gonna lose their
jobs or the knocking other jobs to get
back to so yeah you've got it at the
minute a con a con stress on port this
is you've got to give value you've got
to give value and confidence so you're
talking to a deal seller your your deal
seller on the deal seller I just I just
saw the deal last week and I'm filming
pretty out there like what do you mean
my serve do you mean you've got to give
genuine opportunities to people that are
that are very very lucrative rather than
just selling
average deals have we yeah I'll serve
you mean but I really think I'm gonna
treat my customers right now as if
they're my family and I'm gonna give you
know the best of the best and there
doesent more that I'm gonna keep getting
my face whereas the all the sales people
selling
which deals in an average way you know
suddenly the things are drying up right
now
so you got to be given the best deals
and why is that is that what you mean by
servant that's what yeah that's exactly
what I mean I'm sorry if I didn't
clarify yeah that's exactly what I mean
how do you got just you can't sell an
average deal anymore you certainly si is
si is on its ass the minute
no one's service accommodation because
Airbnb booking.com they've pulled all
the bookings so service cannot get
accommodations massively on its ass I'm
looking at the beat the by refurb
refinance and I think that's a really
really good one minute the issue that
we're gonna have with that is when we do
remove the properties are they gonna
ream or gauge or are they gonna be other
than a value or what they what I work
employee to go they will value up you
just need to make sure you got cushion
because back banks have got money so
this is not like 2008 where where the
banks didn't have any money banks have
got a lot of money the reason that
mortgage companies aren't lending very
easily now is because they physically
can't get to the houses a lot down
property prices are gonna drop they are
dropping the predicts is drop about 15%
this year so I think as long as you
factor that into the day on as long as
you say listen if this drops a bit in
value how much how much I'm not going to
be able to refinance this for if I can't
if I can't refinance it on a 75% loans
value if I can only do it at 65 you just
got it you just got D risk everything by
looking at the worst worst worst case I
think buying a property you store in it
pushing the value up you know as long as
you're buying it the good thing about
BRR is now you can buy heavily the low
market value know you can get bargains
which is going to make easier at the end
so maybe the deals that you were looking
at three months ago you now need to go
back to you with a lower offer you know
stuff there's opportunities be just
different and it's not cheaper know
you've got to adapt kosta go to a - but
don't adapt to the people that are going
to lose right now and then serviced
accommodation I've seen people adapt in
this strategy we've serviced
accommodation I've seen people quit and
I've seen people adapted and I mean my
videos on YouTube I've always said about
serviced accommodation you see people on
windows Wednesday that come on and
they've got like 10 grand a month coming
from serviced accommodation but you'll
see my students I've always been advised
and trained to have more than one leg
holding
the table service accommodation is good
from cash flow right now it's here it's
a business oh yeah my business has been
here cash flow then you invest in long
term wealth you know that's up what kind
of deals what kind of deals are you are
you looking to sell buy what are you
looking at so I'm looking at I'm looking
at stuff down South Wales at the MINIX
and they're all sort of doctored their
dumps their absolute dumps they need a
lot of work doing to them however look
that shape on the video so that again
that was where the house was that I
packaged and sold last week I was also
in South Wales yeah yeah yeah I was I'll
be looking for since I've actually been
looking South Wales since they took it
all off the of the bridge between
Bristol and and the new Newport yeah you
sell the deal and you find a good deal
it's a cracking deal okay how do you
sell it to an investor how do you get
that money right now okay so obviously
you've got to build up yourself a
database of investors you can do that
through you know Facebook social media
obviously look usually usually you know
networking events but you're limited at
the minute you can't do that so the
minute it's all it's all getting on the
phone it's all social media building up
a sort of profile online building up a
bit of a presence online and build up
get it get it get get your database get
email addresses greater a CRM system and
then every time you've got a deal make
sure it's fun you know one day each week
and make sure it's the exact same time
so that you investors look out for it
and then just send out an email you know
to investors tell them that you know
they're gonna go and being such people
are struggling but there are still
people doing deal source and
successfully aren't effective analysts
there he sold deals last week I know
you're selling still
max he's selling I spoke to us I've
spoken to some of my candy members not
selling it's not easy but what I said
what I said recently is if you can sell
during the lockdown and when lockdown
finishes is something gonna feel really
easy hmm and suddenly man like I saw
three deals during the during the month
of lockdown and now lockdown is finished
and I can sell six deals now
hmm you know so how did you get so good
I know I trained you I trained you up a
lot you were you very gracefully made me
attend your deal selling a master
mastery class couple years ago yeah
interesting thing is this like I get
accused because I I'm a salesperson as
well I'm a property investor I'm an
entrepreneur I'm a salesperson my
business man you got a cell and people
will say you know I don't like being
sold to well listen if you don't like
being sold to then you won't sell it
thou less so if you don't like being so
- you better get used to liking it
because otherwise you're gonna have this
conscience of that selling the kids have
a great product of great service find
someone that needs in fits the bill and
then maybe bring the two together that
sell em so people say to me I'm a
salesperson but the thing is I sell
great stuff I sell great property deals
I sell my training programs you wanted
to get good at training training and
stuff I made you go on my training
program my family my sister paid for my
training like that's just it you've done
the deal selling master class and even
now in lockdown as a result the skills
that you learn didn't have to sell you
you still making moment hmm tryam 303
3/9 years later on
yeah I'm still making Mona its kids you
know you it was a great investment it's
three days three days of my life and
it's training I'll take with me for the
rest of my life you know it's tough that
now I'll be doing this till I'm 60 you
don't need 70 will what 28 because
that's the thing the best thing to
invest is property but property can
crumble sometimes as property prices dip
in but the one thing that never take
away when you invest in yourself
knowledge yeah I've this crisis because
you might have got some good property
deals and got lucky by just buying right
and making some money but right now
you're going to be struggling where is
the people that invested in themself and
the entrepreneurs and the smart people
that can adapt and the people that can
sow
yeah but I'm learning every day and you
know are read books every day but now
they're in
now now is the time now it's time to
self educate yourself get yourself
educated because when we do get out this
storm which we will do they can hang
around forever but when we do I'm gonna
be hitting the ground running I'm gonna
be going again and I'm gonna go know
even more now than what I did before and
that this I can't stress this enough
people don't beats people this this is
the time don't sit on your ass watch
Netflix
don't don't don't sit in the garden you
know doing the thing do something with
this time educate yourself get educated
do courses read books do what you can
and then when we get out of this storm
bang because there's gonna be a lot of
beat there's gonna be a lot of
businesses going under with this there's
gonna be a lot of it we've seen it
already with the big businesses going
there's gonna be a lot of big small
businesses that go under this is gonna
[ __ ] a lot of people hmm and you
rather be one of the people get crippled
or or you can just find sit you can you
know educate yourself and when we come
out of this go at it and go at it hard
to this who feels like they're getting
crippled like listen failing and
succeeding are not two different things
you can you can be hitting this storm
right now but that doesn't mean that
you've been at you're not gonna know how
to get through it so you can literally
you could literally you can literally
lose everything you could lose your job
right now people are losing their jobs
and does not mean that you're a failure
that just means that you've got hit hard
by a storm now it's time to get through
it stronger and and since when we go
through the fire we come through we find
them stronger than ever
definitely some sometimes you sometimes
sometimes you've got to face real pains
in order for you in order to grow and
get better make sure it never happens
again this is gonna show people right
now people that were being comfortable
people that had a comfortable job and
had some comfortable analogies I can't
rely on the government I can't rely my
employees I can't rely the only thing on
people can be line right now is
themselves and their skills and I think
that their best skill right now to be
learning these sales because property
business is a people business if you
can't communicate people and you can't
go shave if you can't get deals you know
you lease option agreement deals but you
don't know what to say if you don't have
a package and sell deals if you don't
know how to negotiate below market buy
your deals and use this opportunity as
an excuse to get
absolutely bargain deals but if you
can't articulate that and you don't have
a cell then it's not gonna happen so
that's awesome man I'm excited about
what you're doing bro I'm excited I'm
really excited I'm excited said what we
will look at your different as well the
online stuff that's awesome
yes well the deal selling master class
as well by the way for anyone who's
watching this the deal selling must
guess the same program that Elliott went
on and hundreds of people have paid
thousands of pounds for because on
people used to come to the crash course
and then they'd buy the deal selling
master class and they'd learn how to be
a dealer package under the end upon
winners Wednesday and stuff I think it
was eight to three thousand pounds
that's what people hundreds of people
have paid right now it's online and it's
half that price so Elliott you know all
about that is if maybe I can leave a
I'll leave a description your email and
you can sell them on how to be a good
salesperson I'll leave a link in the
description description and it would you
be happy to talk to somebody a
disclaimer if I give you a small little
amount of Commission when you saw in
people up for the courses that's how
this that's how this rolls then
therefore win for them win for me win
for you but are you happy for me to give
you an put your email in the description
if any wants to contact you you can do
yeah yeah I'm have to give ten twenty
minutes from my time with people if they
want you know it's on any sales tips if
they wanna if they were already deal
sources and I want to learn how to get
better if there weren't any tips yeah we
can I leave my email leave month later
and you need to sell them on the deal
selling masterclass oh well and you
should ring area up just to see how he
sells it to you and even if you have no
no intention of doing the deal selling
mastic us what you really should you
should ring Elliott just to see how he
sells it you'll see our videos because
the same way Elliott's gonna sell the
deal selling masterclass is the exam or
summer deals you sell your deals that's
how you when your busines or somewhere
else so I'll leave your your email send
a little email sound interested in the
deal selling masterclass he'll respond
immediately with his phone number and
then and then boom shacka also you
name's Eliot Spencer so they can add you
on facebook connect with you mmm-hmm
yeah I'm already up I'm all over the
mall over there property investors page
I'm all over your page I'm glad to see
you
I'm glad to see you still winning I'm
appreciative friendship and all I look
for - I look forward to hanging out
having a barbecue wants all the C's over
my frame definitely I need to come see
any bad P family